herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion
wir sind heute hier zu gast im kirchberg
im kanton zürich
hier hat die evangelisch reformierte
kirchgemeinde im frühsommer diesen
jahres eine familie aus tschetschenien
mit vier kindern kirchenasyl gewährt
kirchenasyl
das interessiert uns heute flüchtlinge
das ist sowieso eines der großen themen
in diesem sommer wie soll europa wie
soll die schweiz mit den flüchtlingen
umgehen aufnehmen oder ausschaffen wir
haben zum kirchenasyl eine diskussion
einen film und jetzt erst mal treffe ich
sie bevor die evangelisch reformierte
pfarrerin hier in kilchberg sie bevor
hat die tschetschenische familie im
pfarrhaus bei sich aufgenommen
die kirche und die leute aus der
gemeinde wollten verhindern dass die
familie ausgeschafft wird und haben ihr
kirchenasyl gewährt einen monat lang ist
dies gelungen dann musste die familie
ausreisen
liebevoll haben sie noch kontakt mit der
familie wie geht es der familie
wir haben kontakt wir haben kontakt via
what's up das ist ja heute einfach man
kann auf der ganzen welt in verbindung
sein und per wap haben wir auch kontakt
nach ja also sie sind im umkreis von
genau und vor allem mit den kindern vor
allem mit den mädchen die mädchen
schreiben fleißig sie natürlich im engen
kontakt mit den familien wo sie da gut
befreundet sind und auch mit den
freundinnen die sie hatten und freunden
und mit uns auch sie schreiben immer
wieder mal sie schreiben immer dass sie
um sehr vermissen also das leben hier
vermissen sie haben heimweh kann man
sagen sie sind es ihnen immer noch in
einem für sie komplett fremden land und
jetzt dann wird es interessant ob sie in
die schule gehen können wenn sie
sprechen überhaupt kein russisch und
russisch ist die amtssprache auch in
tschetschenien und dementsprechend muss
man auch russisch sprechen können wenn
man die schule besuchen will
also ein steiniger einstieg bis es für
den vater er hat er gesagt er ist
bedroht sie sind ja während des ramadans
ausgeschafft worden und da hatten sie
ein bisschen luft weil eigentlich keine
kriegerischen handlungen während des
ramadans da hat er sich auch ein
bisschen geschützt gefühlt dass sie
nichts geschehen wird und aus der
ramadan zu ende war
da hat man sehr stark gespürt dass er
jetzt wirklich angst hat die angst ist
da die angst ist auch bei der mutter da
was wäre wenn wenn dieser fahrzeug
wieder verschwindet amnesty
international and das ja die
verschwundene nehmen die man wirklich
das kennt man das benennt man so in
tschetschenien und da verschwinden
einfach männer in leder sie werden
verhaftet und man weiß nicht wohin sie
gebracht werden oder sie können wirklich
von der straße weg verschwinden und das
wäre das natürlich die größte
katastrophe
insbesondere auch für die mädchen man
kennt die zwangsverheiratung in
tschetschenien und unter umständen sie
sind dann nicht mehr geschützt das
könnte passieren
sie haben den ramadan angedeutet also
die familie das sind muslime hier im
pfarrhaus er ihn war das ein thema ja
das war ein thema dass wenn wir
gemeinsam trainiert haben was dann das
schöne wetter zugelassen hat dass wir
das konnten haben wir natürlich kein
schwein
die flasche geleert sonst war das
eigentlich kein thema wenn wir sagen
auch kurzzeit an gesagt haben sie hat
gesagt in china sie tragen keine
kopftücher die mutter nicht und auch die
die mädchen nicht die mädchen waren
komplett sogenannt westlich gekleidet
kurze hosen an träger t shirt und das
ist auch eine große umstellung jetzt das
dürfen sie natürlich nicht mehr tragen
in tschetschenien sie müssen röcke
tragen kopftücher tragen das seil war
für sich sehr fremd familie hat ja
mehrere jahre hier gelebt war offenbar
gut integriert warum eigentlich habt ihr
von der gemeinde und ein großes
unterstützungskomitee ihnen kirchenasyl
gewährt
die familie war wie gesagt sehr gut
integriert das heißt sie hat auch sehr
viele freundschaften gepflegt ihren
kirchberg und als dann bekannt wurde
dass diese familie nicht hier bleiben
kann ist dieser entscheid auf sehr viel
unverständnis gestoßen
es haben sich familien hier engagiert
haben dieses unterstützungskomitee hier
zuhause gegründet haben auf diesen fall
aufmerksam gemacht und trotzdem ist dann
die familie alles versucht worden sie
aus zu schaffen das ist nicht gelungen
das muss eine sehr dramatische erfahrung
gewesen sein für die familie ist seit
diesem ausschaffungs versuch haben sie
wirklich in ständiger angst gelebt es
wurde ein zweiter anschaffungs versuch
unternommen und das vordringlichste ziel
war erst mal dass eine solche
zwangsausschaffung nicht mehr
stattfindet das ist ja gelungen der
verfehlungen im kirchenasyl sind sie
nicht mehr sie konnten nicht sie konnten
nicht hier bleiben selbstverständlich
haben wir immer gehofft bis zur letzten
sekunde kauft vielleicht ein bisschen
leid aber wir haben wirklich immer
gehofft dass sie hier bleiben können
aber das bundesverwaltungsgericht hat
dreimal
wir haben ja alles versucht juristisch
dreimal gesagt nein diese familie muss
die schweiz verlassen nach
tschetschenien zurückkehren wie seid ihr
dann auf die idee gekommen sie könnten
eventuell ihr bleiben
ich sage ja vielleicht war das eine
gewisse naivität wir haben einfach
gehofft dass dieser spielraum der jede
behörde hat dieser ermessensspielraum
dass das nochmal überdacht werden dass
man irgendwo denkt ja doch die familie
kam bleiben die haben aber damit
gerechnet dass sie gehen muss und wir
wollten einfach dass sie nicht
zwangsweise gehen muss er das nicht eine
ungerechtigkeit gegenüber anderen die
dann einfach sagen wir gehen jetzt
freiwillig ich finde es ganz schwierig
natürlich es gibt so viele familien die
auch das recht hätten hier zu bleiben es
ist immer ein 1 1 ab wegen das ist ganz
klar und letzten endes habe ich große
hochachtung vor den behörden die diese
schwierigen entscheidungen treffen
müssen
in diesem ich kann nur für diesen fall
sprechen diesem fall wir in kirchberg
wurden konfrontiert mit dieser not der
familie
wir haben wir dann auf engstem raum also
das parkhaus ist groß aber wir haben
zusammen gelebt und ich habe diese die
mutter hatte ständig panikattacken die
kinder haben sind aufgewacht in der
nacht bringen eine autotüre zugeschlagen
als war immer dann sind haben sie
geweint durch gemeint die ganze nacht
weil sie gedacht haben jetzt kommt dann
wieder die polizei und holt sie raus und
wir wollten einfach der familie etwas
ruhe und etwas zeit verschaffen und auch
dass sie nicht mehr alleine sind wir
haben sind im ständigen kontakt
natürlich gewesen mit der familie ich
habe viel mit der mutter gesprochen mit
den kindern gesprochen
mein anfang hat ein sehr enges
verhältnis zum vater der familie
gepflegt konnten sie er konnte viel mit
ihnen sprechen und ich glaube das hat
der familie sehr gut getan zumindest
haben sie uns das so gespiegelt danke
für diesen einblick in dieses
kirchenasyl in kirchberg das kirchenasyl
gibt es in der schweiz nicht oft aktuell
gibt es einen fall in lausanne in einer
katholischen kirchgemeinde ganz anders
ist das in deutschland
dort gibt es eine große bewegung eine
kirchliche bewegung und es gibt eine
ökumenische arbeitsgemeinschaft für asyl
in der kirche
der folgende filmbeitrag der begleitet
drei asylsuchende in bayern im
kirchenasyl und danach diskutieren wir
im studio pro und contra kirchen
ziel